je suis français
nous y sommes
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il me trouve
tout le monde me regarde à travers mon
innocence je pense qu'il me charme
la maîtresse d'école m'a dit que j'étais
chez moi mais mon papa lui pourtant se
méfie d'elle
était fidèle
la france est belle même regard de haut
comme la tour eiffel et pèse mes parents
m'ont pas mis au monde pour toucher les
aides
bl j'ai vu que marion madoui t'es quoi
elle se mêle
je sais qu'elle m'aime
je suis français
tu loues trouve 3
laquelle merci d'être là mon chéri tu es
vraiment éternel insatisfait déjà
disponibles réédition de l'album car
fait un carton et qui continue à faire
un carton il a été formidable
j'adore est ce que je viens de voir
booba disto d'ailleurs le sosie de booba
en train de manger a banni ce taux cette
fois c'est bel âge que j'ai vu date jus
d'orange
ces dates du qui boit un jus d'orange
pressé ou est ce que j'ai vu blackman m
aaa c'est-à-dire black m avec un
personnage amène m alors à votre avis la
gamme déjà c'est sûr que non parce que
je suis en train de lui parler
actuellement la promesse âge donc c'est
le sosie de booba oui je pensais que ses
amis avaient choisi de booba le sosie
booba et ouais vous pouvez regarder
toile et chaussées une banane son parti
qu'il se cache dans le rideau bleu
[Applaudissements]
sa maman car tout
je suis français
venez voir
et on sait
elle parce qu'ils me trouvent autre
danser
qu'est ce cas là je parle à mon pote
bienvenus ce qu'il a dit ce qu'il a dit
bien vite nous voir frères bedimo jours
à calage criminelle non j'ai pas eu
cette chance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci
je suis français
tomassi on sait
pda
je suis en scène
et voilà
ce qu'il veut
tu la connais très bien kanye je ne
connais pas très bien mais je pense
qu'elle a regardé ça veut dire ça va tu
la connais très bien
le drone est mené depuis travaillé
dessus bah oui ça va arrêter de croire
qu'il ya toujours un guichet la roche
mais la roche
[Musique]
je
je suis beurre je suis jaune je suis
blanc je suis un être humain comme toi
je suis chez moi j'en ai deux français
pierre d'adieu
monsieur diallo
[Musique]